ronnie was absolute perfectionist the
fiercest competitor ever so the trick is
to always peel back or why am I doing
this in the first place
my greatest gift was not so much
whatever physical attributes but it was
just stubborn and being isolated need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation what's that believe nation it's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
starting skateboarding at age 10 even
though his father didn't approve to
becoming a world champion age 14 and
becoming one of the greatest street
skaters of all time
he's rodney mullen and here's my take on
his top ten rows of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one believe one thing that happens all
the time is skateboarding and I think
for minute miles side it often happens
best dudes around the world can be
striving after one particular trick
finally one guy does it and then the
rest has come like living rarely is it a
question of talent or technique at those
levels it's just one of belief and the
concomitant will to kind of do something
that either no one's done before or even
more I think the crack opened the
barriers that people considered
impossible or undoable and that kind of
belief I think is rarer than Talent
talent is it's around to having both of
those levels there's only a few people
that they really have that I think in
the history they're the ones that have
really changed things rule number two be
on the next level Ronnie was absolute
perfectionist the fiercest competitor
ever I mean he he knew every single my
new thing he was going to do exactly
what his feet really do the order was
going to happen if Rodney stepped off
his board or anything like that
he probably devastated rodney was a
competitor on an olympic scale that I've
never witnessed in my life he was
flawless perfect every time getting to
second to him was like getting first
nobody deserved to ever take a spot and
that's when the rumors flew that he was
practicing nine hours a day are we going
I know hours a day how's that possible
rule number three build resilience
[Music]
[Applause]
in order to achieve greatness you have
to go through a lot of pain
you definitely have setbacks but in
order to achieve that success you have
to push through you're gonna have to
battle injury
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the thing that stuck with me most about
skating or that it's given me over the
years I think the ability to just go
back to something for the sake of loving
it and falling is so integrated into us
a lot of people don't fall as much as we
do in every level and we're falling
becomes normal and picking yourself up
again is normal and I think the the kind
of resilience the skaters have is
uncommon in call it regular life rule
number four have a strong why I think
the successes of winning right you want
to be their best in the neighborhood and
then win the local contest and then
whatever whatever it's it just keeps
going up and then by the time you get
there you can have a stadium screaming
your name it's actually happened a
couple of times to me and there is a
visceral exhilaration to it there is
I've experienced that I know what that's
like you land a trick in there it just
lights up it's crazy at the same time
it's hollow it's hollow that's not the
thing that can drive you at least not
for long it's being able to say oh I had
that I had a model or I had people are
there or whatever all of these honors
eventually that stuff phased to just
static and you're left with you and your
board and if you decide that that's what
you love that's what you're doing then
your days are numbered and so the trick
is to always peel back of why am I doing
this in the first place
oh yeah I still oh my god I'm still that
kid on the farm you know and I cling to
that even the things they're hurt rule
number five be passionate and there's
something called a primo slide
this is the funnest chick ever to do
it's like skimboarding this will slide
sideways every which way
okay so when you're skating and you take
a fall the board sits that way or that
way kind of predictable this goes every
which way it's like a cartoon the Falls
and that's what I love the most about it
it's so much fun to do in fact when I
started doing them I remember because I
got hurt I hadn't I had to get a knee
surgery right so there are a couple of a
couple of days where actually a couple
of weeks where I couldn't skate at all
it would give out on me I would watch
the guys I'd go this warehouse with a
lot of guys were skating my friends I
was like man I gotta do something new I
want to do something new I don't start
fresh and start fresh and so the night
before my surgery I watched and was like
how am I gonna do this so I ran up and I
jumped on my board and I came and I
flipped it down and I remember thinking
I landed so I put a bigger than if my
knee gives they'll just have more work
to do in the morning surgery but you
were so helpless right you're on this
gurney are you watching the ceiling come
right every time it's always that and
right when they're putting the mask on
you before you go to sleep
all I was thinking is man when I wake up
and I get better the first thing I'm
gonna do is film that trick rule number
six
be authentic number one I goes way back
that is whoever Henry Sanchez had such a
distinctive thing with his arm when he
would push and of course man like you
look up to Harry Sanchez cuz he was
amazing but you see people pushing
around like him you're like dude here
you know you're an idiot stop you're
just trying to be like him that's not
you yeah but I'm doing what looks
freaking awesome yeah but you it's not
awesome because it's not you that's the
point well that's that's what allowed me
to do what I did I think my greatest
gift was not so much whatever physical
attributes but it was just stubborn and
being isolated
you know just loving tumbling something
around for the sake of tumbling around
and seeing what comes out it's always
been me so that's still there that's me
rule number seven do what you love I
still am most comfortable with skating I
just go out on their streetlights
somewhere and I I do this stuff and I
get peace I can think
and a skateboarding to me you know is
creating something that's cool you know
I mean who knows what really drives
someone to progress it could be fear or
competition or being basically tormented
by ideas that's just gonna force you to
progress argue go crazy
every time he goes out escapes he sees
something else out there they will just
start going after it
he just loves what he's doing
rule number 8 embrace failure another
form of this
[Music]
that's Carlos so notice first thing he
does there's so much I can view this the
lens of balance is he's looking out that
ledge you ollie out far it's a lower
ollie and safer in a sense but you're
going faster you go slower higher ollie
see gage he hops up there whatever you
do don't fall left and then he gauges
this so what does it feel like the
incline figure that out and then look at
the cement how's that gonna grind I mean
am I gonna stick and pitch forward or is
a lot of whacks am I gonna whip out he
hops down another sense of balance is if
you're around these guys at all you
learn this quickly whatever you do don't
think about it too much because if you
do you start project images of disaster
that will lock you up and get you out of
sync and sends you to the hospital so he
goes back he charges he stops it last
minutes hearts racing because because
it's deadly he goes back commits and
makes it and it's amazing it's not
always like that though
[Music]
one of the hard things about putting
together this footage was what not to
put in because there's so much of this
failure pain injury recovery it is
embedded into their notion of what it is
to be a skateboarder these individuals
know that feel that I don't skate like
that again but I'm familiar enough with
it good dozen broken bones as far as
contracts you sign on the dotted line
they're agreeing to pay you for what you
can do but they know they're going to be
paying you for when you can't skate when
you're healing it's unrealistic to
expect constant progress because the
nature of what we're trying to do is
going to new realms to break new
barriers and what's concomitant with
that is not knowing exactly what to do
you got to switch around a little bit so
by the very nature the ethos of our
community I think it's more conducive to
innovation I'm clearly biased but I do
believe skateboarding is unusually
innovative and part of the reason is
because of the way we embrace failure as
a community what I would like to share
from my community is the importance of
failure and the power of getting up
again and the dident the dynamic they
form so hopefully I can pass that on in
to yours and go from there rule number
nine be a creator I think I was on tour
when I was really one of the fine line
biographies is the red one of the blue
one and he made this he made this
statement that was so profound to me it
was it that the the Nobel Prize was the
tombstone on all great work and it
resonated because I had won 35 out of 36
contests that I've entered over 11 years
and it made me banana
in fact winning isn't the word I want at
once the rest of time you're just
defending and you get into this like
turtle posture you know where you're not
doing it
it usurped the joy of what I love to do
because I was no longer doing it to
create and have fun and when it died out
from under me that was one of the most
liberating things because I could create
and look I understand that I am on the
very edge of preachy right here I'm not
here to do that it's just that I'm in
front of a very privileged audience if
you guys aren't already leaders in your
community you probably will be if
there's anything I can give you that
will transcend what I've gotten from
skateboarding the only things of
meanings I think in a permanence it's
not saying stop popping that's all they
say it's what it is is if there's a
trinsic value in creating something for
the sake of creating it and better than
that because man I'm 46 year old I'll be
46 and how pathetic is that that I'm
still skateboarding but there is there
is this beauty in you dropping it into a
community of your own making and see
dispersed and say younger more talented
just different Talent take it to levels
you could never imagine because that
lives on and rule number 10 the last
home before a very special bonus clip is
master your craft
[Music]
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Rodney on how to be driven that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
into the questions in the comments below
here we go question number one what is
your craft that you need to master
number two what recent failure do you
need to do a better job of embracing and
number three what does the next level
look like for you
so over time you had these injuries
where your femur was grinding into your
hip and basically they just said wanted
to hang it up now is the time but
instead of doing that you spent years if
I'm not mistaken breaking the scar
tissue apart in an insanely painful
fashion walk us through that what was
that what was the process how long did
you stick at it yeah that was heavy you
know I remember I used to talk to Tony a
lot because we're you know he's close
he's Tony Hawk at hawk
yeah he's good as people come isolde
smart and I had scar tissue that somehow
got around the joint and so every time
he'd flex muscles and the biggest ones
in your body it would pull the femur
into the socket and it would grind maybe
20 times a day turnover when you're
sleeping whatever again brake to
accelerator you feel them and it was
worse and worse to the point where you
couldn't fall and roll and she can't
fall and rolled and what do you get you
can't skate and I went to the dock and
swim the East Coast a couple pictures
friend and he said with his eyes what he
wouldn't say in words because he cared
for me so much that he gave me this
little tool basically they can't cut you
open because there's so much that
generates more so what do you do this is
what retires people scar tissue and
you've got to the point what's gonna
grind off their head and any bones
grinding it'll calcify and stick right
so that's what was happening and I
remember when it stopped moving like a
ball-and-socket to more of a stick shift
so I'm hobbling around and things are
pretty dark for me and if you're a champ
if your whole identity is expressed
through what you do and then it's gone
will you become a mess a lot of people
do we see it right
child actor first thing in mind what is
it and they showed me that you can like
a masseuses elbow the fascia fasciae the
pressure on is the only thing to
deactivate it so you can pull a little
bit
so I started sticking this little
plastic thing and I started breaking on
pasta curves which are awesome and I
would realize that it's relaxing stuff
and I can get my leg around particularly
fire hydrants because then they have
those they have the separate stems and
you could put them in you and then you
can reach over and stretch and then get
leverage because I'm not that strong and
so then you can use your body weight as
leverage to pull things and then you
start to get to discern over this is an
hour to it a day and you use you're
skating is like a micrometer when you're
walking you don't know your bounce but
if you're on a board or a tightrope you
know you're about and so I would pull
pull pull and I would find there are
strings you can tell it's not you you
know I all right
gradually pull this is after hundreds of
hours you get more courage and you
become everything you need to know has
already been said right it is desperate
people do desperate things and necessity
is the mother of all invention all you
need to know I was desperate and I
needed to break free and so I just
Ratchet it up and it takes a while to
get used to the pain but you keep it's
like all those karate guys kicking
bamboo you get tougher does it make you
tough but you get tougher if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be can like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more wisdom from
skateboarders check out the top 10 I did
on Tony Hawk it's right there next to me
I think you're going to enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there it's above winning a contest it's
about like that one time this is what I
love doing